Oh man, I can't believe this is where we are.
But Donald Trump has been caught
on our recording during a private event yesterday,
implying that the Ukraine whistle blower should
be killed, should be executed.
Um, it's not just the media that Donald Trump
has no respect for.
Uh, it's also whistleblowers.
It's really anyone who doesn't pray at the
altar of Trump.
And this apparently includes killing people.
Uh, Donald Trump spoke yesterday to a group
of us diplomatic staff in New York city and
it was recorded.
The LA times got their hands on the recording
and Trump implies that whistle blowers should
be killed like we used to do with treasonous.
People.
Take a listen to this.
Basically that person never saw the report,
never saw the call, and he never saw the call,
heard something and decided that he or she,
you have the holiday, sort of like almost
a spy.
I want to know who's the person that gave
the whistleblower, Liz, the person who gave
the whistleblower the information.
Cause that's was to as fi, you know what we
used to do in the old days where we respired
the spies.
And Theresa, we used to handle it a little
differently than we do them.
Right?
You know what we used to do in the old days
to people to who make KU commit treason.
Donald Trump is talking about killing whistle
blowers and then people in the room laugh
and you know, I dunno if those are nervous
laughs or laughs of agreement, but the president
is effectively saying, here, I wish I could
have Americans who are inconvenient to me,
politically executed.
And there are reports of this recording summarizing
it as Trump slams the whistle blower.
It's not that Trump is slamming the whistleblower.
Donald Trump is suggesting that the whistle
blower should be executed.
And that is obviously much, much worse.
And it's not a surprise look at which relationships
have failed under Donald Trump and which brutal
dictators.
He is absolutely enamored with friends Canada,
Germany, the UK, our relationships with those
countries, those, uh, Western dipper diplomatic,
uh, a democratic historical allies, our relationships
with them are worse than they've been in a
very, very long time under Donald Trump.
And then on the other hand, Donald Trump is
just smitten with Putin.
And Duterte and Kim Jong UN and urge to one.
And you know, I can't even remember the full
list off hand.
We've since found out, uh, over the last day
or so that the whistleblower, by the way,
the first whistleblower w there's now news
of another whistleblower and IRS whistleblower,
and we'll talk about that on Monday.
We've now found out that the Ukraine whistleblower
is believed to be a CIA officer who was working
at the white house.
And as you can imagine, the whistle blower
would be at immediate risk if information
about them were published.
Now, before we even knew that this was a CIA
officer, I said, if the whistle blower's identity
becomes public, I would be extremely scared
to be anywhere in public.
That Trump is, might be because that person's
life is immediately at risk.
But even beyond that, now we know, or it's
being reported by the New York times, that
this is a CIA officer, their identity needs
to be protected.
Hopefully it will be the CIA is saying that
protecting the identity of the whistleblower,
is there a quote, highest priority.
And I hope that that's the case.
I would not be surprised.
I, I hate to even dabble in this, but if by
Monday, uh, we find out that Donald Trump
has tweeted the name or some other information
about the whistleblower, if it becomes known
to him, it would be disgusting.
It would be deplorable.
It would be, uh, one of the worst things that
I can imagine, but it would not be altogether
surprising.
And we will follow up on this on Monday.
We will tell you about the second whistleblower
on Monday and there's so much more going on.